la parole est maintenant monsieur gérard
larcher pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire oui monsieur le
président madame la ministre est cher
collègue mais système des retraites est
un des indicateurs d'un modèle social
celui que nous avons mis en place il y a
longtemps dans notre pays est basée sur
la solidarité des générations
il est depuis longtemps en difficulté et
celles et ceux qui l'ont préservée
défendu ce sont les gouvernements
d'edouard balladur et de jacques chirac
jean pierre raffarin et françois fillon
puis en 2003 les gouvernements sous
l'autorité de nicolas sarkozy avec
françois fillon
beaucoup a été fait mais la réalité liée
à notre taux d'activité notre
démographie notre situation économique
et sociale n'est qu'il nous faut
poursuivre et approfondir encore les
réformes engagées au fond il faut
inverser ce qui a été décidé sans étude
prospective simplement par un choix
politique c'était la proposition 82 de
françois mitterrand en 1981 la retraite
à 60 ans était sympathique et pourtant
des élus aussi peu réactionnaire que
philippe seguin et jacques chaban delmas
avait prévenu et je cite par les coûts
supplémentaires qui pèseront sur des
régimes de retraite déjà en difficulté
le gouvernement prend le risque de
compromettre l'avenir alors aujourd'hui
il va falloir et à contre-pied d'une
attitude constante de la gauche depuis
20 ans examinés l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation la contribution de
tous
la convergence progressive des trois
systèmes pour ma part attaché à l'équité
je prendrai le courage de parler du
report de l'âge mais en prenant en
compte la pénibilité et le taux
d'activité des seniors qui est un vrai
sujet de la convergence progressive des
régimes publics privés et spéciaux sans
oublier qu'il ya des fonctionnaires je
pense notamment aux territoriaux dont
les retraites sont modestes mon refus de
voir comme paramètre la désindexation et
nous voyons bien que ce sujet est entré
subrepticement dans le cadre de la
négociation agirc arrco et sans doute
va-t-il une indexation sur la croissance
vous l'avez dit vous-même quand on vit
plus longtemps on peut travailler plus
longtemps alors ma question est double
appliquerez vous le dispositif de la loi
de 2010 adoptée ici sur la réforme du
système et dont je rappelle que dans la
loi nous devons mettre en place des
groupes de travail cette année certes il
faudra du temps mais comme la cfdt je
crois qu'il ya là une voix qui répond à
la pérennité et l'équité et vitré vous
de paupériser les retraités vous êtes au
pied du mur madame la ministre est ce
que vous n'avez pas fait en nous
accompagnant depuis 20 ans il va falloir
aujourd'hui le faire sans faux fuyant
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement n'a
pas l'intention de prendre quelques
chemins de traverse que ce soit et il
n'a pas l'intention non plus de se
laisser dicter une réforme parce qu il y
a deux ans prétendait répondre à
l'ensemble des défis que rencontrent nos
régimes de retraites pour que nous nous
trouvions deux ans après aujourd'hui
trois ans mais deux ans après avec le
constat implacable d'un déficit qui
s'accroît et d'une justice sociale battu
en brèche et donc le gouvernement va
mettre en place la concertation
nécessaire pour mettre en pla pour
proposer une réforme globale qui ne soit
pas simplement une réforme comptable car
la réforme comptable ne permettent pas
de répondre aux grands enjeux liés à la
question de la retraite mais une réforme
qui inscrivent dans la durée à la fois
nos régimes de retraite par répartition
et la solidarité entre les générations
la volonté du gouvernement et qu'à
l'occasion de la réforme qui engage soit
garanti le financement de l'ensemble des
régimes de retraite d'ici 2020 que soit
donnée ou rendu confiance aux jeunes
générations dans l'avenir de nos
systèmes de retraite en introduisant des
mécanismes de financement de ces régimes
à un horizon plus lointain et en
envisageant des dispositifs qui
permettent régulièrement de revoir la
situation financière de ces régimes et
enfin réforme qui doit proposer des
mesures de justice car et vous l'avez
vous-même indiqué nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui à des personnes qui ont de
toutes petites retraites je pense en
particulier à certains agriculteurs
je pense par exemple aux femmes je pense
à celles et ceux qui ont eu des
carrières hachées et c'est donc cette
vision globale que nous voulons porter
dans le cadre du système de retraite par
répartition car monsieur le sénateur la
réforme que nous engageons évidemment
vos remise à plat des systèmes et de la
réforme de 2010 c'est avec les
partenaires sociaux le travail que nous
avons mises en place pour que l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et en particulier
celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur l'avenir de leur
retraite puisse compter sur des pensions
de niveaux satisfaisants et qui leur
permettent d'envisager l'avenir avec
sérénité
pour une courte réplique monsieur le
président monsieur le
président on à mme la ministre au delà
des mots il va avoir eu la nécessité de
prendre des décisions et pardonnez moi
ces décisions ça ne pouvait pas être
qu'un ensemble de mots sympathique
chaleureux il y aura des réalités et
parmi ces réalités là il y aura la
convergence qu'on le veuille ou non le
système de retraite et parmi les
réalités il y aura la réflexion sur la
contribution des uns et des autres avec
en même temps quand on parle de
compétitivité d'emploi et bien la
réalité qu'on ne peut pas peser ni sur
les entreprises nées sur les salariés
car cette réalité là elle va s'imposer à
nous et je dois dire que attaché que je
suis au système par répartition je pense
que nous devons refonder progressivement
le système ça se passera pas j'allais
dire en un tour de main mais s'il ne le
faisons pas comme nous en avons décidé
le principe en 2010 collectivement je me
souviens du débat alors nous aurons
manquer ce rendez vous à tous les cas
vous êtes au pied du mur si vous prenez
les bonnes décisions on les soutiendra
mais si vous prenez les chemins de
traverse nous serons au travers de ces
choix là